we've got one last story we hope brings
a smile to your face this is what I'm
liking it is no secret that I'm a huge
advocate of reading early and reading
often but there just aren't many books
for kids who are visually impaired
that's why we want to shine a light on a
Detroit woman who's printing children's
books in Braille and getting them into
the hands of kids all over the world
it's amazing it's the perfect story for
this Braille literacy month let's say hi
to Deborah the founder of seedlings
watching on WXYZ TV what's up
Deborah fast so excited well we are
honored to have you on the show so why
have kids books and Braille been so few
and far between you know that was my
question like way back in 1980 I met a
mom whose daughter was blind and she
said they had a hard time getting books
for her if they could find them they
were so expensive like $100 to $200 each
Kelly and that just hurt my heart
because my own kids had you you can get
books for two three do yeah and that's
what kids need lots and lots of books so
I I thought I could do something about
it maybe I started a small nonprofit in
my basement in Detroit called seedlings
baril books for children U making more
books available keeping the prices
really low and getting more books in
kids hands absolutely it's such a cool
thing that you're doing and you have a
portion of seedlings that honors your
late daughter right can you tell us
about it yeah so um my daughters were
one and three years old they're right
around your age Kelly um and when I
started seedlings and then they grew up
with it they they L books they suggested
titles they uh worked there in high
school but when the older one Anna went
off to college unfortunately um her car
was was hit by a drunk driver and she
she passed and of course I was
devastated um but with family and faith
and seedlings I you know it gave me
things to to keep me going um lots of
people sent Memorial donations very
generous donations in her name so we
decided to start a program to honor her
and we were selling the books at a loss
making the prices low but with this new
program called the book Angel program uh
we're able to give books away and at
first it was just one book per child in
the United States and now it's five
books for all the kids in the United
States and Canada so we're giving away
like two-thirds of the books we send out
now and it's getting so many more books
in the hands of the kids with vision
loss it's just been wonderful that it is
very wonderful what you're doing um
especially in honor of your daughter
thank you Deborah I'm loving your post
right now we love you oh well thank you
so much but that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of precise
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable people
just like you ma'am so they're going to
be riding you a check for seedling for
$1,000 how's that
sound thank you so much yeah thank you
so much Deo we're doing this so cool so
important and thank you to all of our
guest this hour Daisy Ridley
lisand and have a great it's
[Music]
not
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home